i don't often talk about this on the
show um but i've mentioned off and on
that i've owned bitcoin for a long time
and
over the last 24 hours i got like 10 or
12 different requests to talk about
what's going on with bitcoin
and it's in the news so much in the last
day or two that i think it does make
sense to talk about it in the last week
we've seen
some major mainstreaming of bitcoin
and at this point the idea that it's
just going to go away is seeming very
very unlikely to me and i'm going to
explain to you why but to give you some
examples of the main streaming of
bitcoin recently
here is for example amc entertainment
which owns uh movie theaters ceo adam
aaron
who says
they are going to start accepting
bitcoin litecoin and ethereum before the
end of the year and dogecoin next year
take a look at this yeah we've said
we're going to that we're going to
accept before you end
we will accept bitcoin uh litecoin
ethereum dogecoin all by year uh all all
by right now for amc gift cards yeah by
year-end for bitcoin litecoin ethereum
one i think we'll be able to take those
coin in q1 so again changes we're
we're entering the 21st century in a big
way we've also learned over time and
some of these decisions were actually
made made long ago
about how more and more college
endowments as well as financial advisory
type companies are holding or
recommending holding some percentage of
assets in cryptocurrency some examples
the harvard management company has
invested in bitcoin since 2019 according
to one report
the brown university endowment
has invested in cryptocurrency now um
for some period of time
jp morgan is now or has been since about
six months ago suggesting to investors
maybe look at putting one percent of
your portfolio in bitcoin
morgan stanley has actually started
offering its wealthy clients access to
bitcoin funds and a number of new funds
and etfs have gone live even in the last
several weeks
just picking different things to show
you the breadth of this
nba owner mark cuban says that soon
uh the mavericks will accept dogecoin
for tickets to the games
and the mavericks have long been except
long for some period of time have
already been accepting
bitcoin for payment as well
so all of these things together what
what is the point here i guess is the
question this is not a segment about
is bitcoin good or is bitcoin bad
in fact
the the longer bitcoin is around
it's sort of like saying is the dollar
good or is the dollar bad these are
financial technologies that exist
and really it's about how are they used
how are they regulated what do they mean
etc this is not about is bitcoin used
for criminal transactions sure it is the
the dollar is still the primary currency
used for criminal transactions not a
super interesting conversation for this
segment what about energy use for
bitcoin mining an important topic for
sure
not the topic of this particular
conversation the conversation today is
is this going to be merely a passing fad
and it seems tougher and tougher to
argue that bitcoin is going to be a
passing fad now notice that i haven't
talked in this segment
about the price of bitcoin yesterday
today
bitcoin roughly equaled its all-time
high
of about 64 000 per coin
um
this is about adoption and this is about
use
it's tough to imagine bitcoin just
evaporating could it be regulated into
obscurity at this point maybe maybe but
it would really require coordinated
action by lots of governments and even
then i'm unsure there are etfs there are
funds mainstream funds and etfs which
are based on cryptocurrency at this
point in time now am i recommending
anyone do anything in particular
absolutely not
that's not what the show is about this
is not a segment about buy bitcoin or
sell bitcoin or i think bitcoin will be
worth x at any point in time that's not
it at all
i wondered if
this might be something with lasting
potential back in 2015
and so i bought bitcoin back then and a
few other coins and as they've gone up
in value i've sold pieces of my holdings
to lock in gains all with the idea that
i have no idea where this is going to go
but now my thinking is as follows
nasim nicholas talib wrote the book the
black swan
wrote the book anti-fragile as well as
other books very interesting work uh
nasim nicholas talib and he says you
know in thinking about like for example
what books to read and what has stood
the test of time and likely will
continue to he says
you know if something's been around for
500 years and people keep reading it
it's quite plausible that it's going to
be around and people are going to keep
reading it for another 500 years that
might be something worth reading maybe
if the topic is interesting and you know
everybody make a decision for yourself a
book that's been around for a year
we can say it'll probably be around
another year but it's harder to say
it'll probably be around another 500
years and in fact most books written in
the last year are not going to be read
500 years from now
um along the same lines bitcoin was
created in 2009
that's now been 12 almost 13 years
it's hard to imagine it going poof in
the next month
it's hard to imagine it going poof in
the next year
and so the longer that it goes
particularly
when you see trade volume so high
and the price is certainly a signal as
well
it becomes more and more reasonable to
think
it's going to continue being around and
that's a really interesting change from
what was being said in 2011 and what was
being said in 2013. so again just to be
really really clear
i have no idea what the price of bitcoin
is going to be
i'm not suggesting anyone buy or sell it
but at this point as a financial
technology it seems as though it's here
to stay
and it's quite plausible that it's been
here almost 12 almost 13 years it's
quite plausible to me it's going to be
around another 12 or 13 years at that
point it will be 26 years
and if it can make it that long
it becomes even harder to imagine that
it's just going to disappear that's my
perspective at this point in time
i'm curious to hear from folks and
please comment on what i've actually
said
which has nothing to do with what i
expect the price of bitcoin to be i've
not said a word about that one of our
sponsors is privacy.com they're giving
you five dollars when you sign up for
their completely free service at
privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them you can delete them
anytime you want so when you do this it
means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a ten dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create 36 credit cards a month
and a 25 a month plan tailored more for
small businesses where you can create 60
card numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
pacman